hello folks I hope I'm on says that I'm
on but I don't see myself
so I would think that
if you have any message for me let me
know if you can hear me if you can see
me
[Music]
sound is okay thank you
how about me can you see me
okay I rebooted my computer I'm using a
different computer that's the issue and
uh I'm not familiar with some of these
things in YouTube I do the best I can
here
okay so let's get started I'm gonna be
talking a little bit about
uh ether someone asked questions about
or had some issues with ether I'm going
to talk a little bit about shape there
were some questions about shape and
about field and about Ray and then I'll
get into Consciousness uh but let us
start with our uh Extinction segment uh
some issues there as well uh first of
all I can say regarding the Ukraine war
which is a big issue but it's falling
kind of like low in the news
um and you have both sides both sides
say they're winning the war as always
all the military always Ace you know and
on each side say we're doing just great
you know uh the 60s and 70 year old
people make the war in the 20 and the 30
year olds fight it and die for it uh
would you die for Al Capone
well these people say that they're
designing for the country which is more
or less the same thing
okay so there's not much going on there
uh just uh we're waiting for them to
reach some kind of agreement some kind
of treaty and all those people who died
well nobody will remember them for sure
in fact uh all I can say to you is the
following you do you remember anyone who
died in the Civil War or in World War
One or the Napoleonic Wars or of course
not nobody remembers them and even if
you did doesn't do them any good they're
out
okay so so much for that but let me look
at something else there's this uh fellow
I talked about a couple times now and
because it's been on the news lately his
name is ABI lib Loeb I'm not sure how to
pronounce his last name
um and he's a Harvard professor and this
is the issue the issue is that if you're
a Harvard Professor like in astrophysics
uh well you got a big title and so you
have a lot of persuasion power right so
people listen to them thinking that
they're going to get some information
that's valuable and this fellow is into
ETS you know he's trying to push this uh
this issue into the public uh possibly
to become famous make some money you
know all of that or all of the above you
know and uh this fellow sometime back a
couple years back he was the guy
involved with
um
you can get it here drop down the other
side
give me a second here let me get it up
there again
and here's the guy who um came up with
this the uh Umama as I call it the you
Mama a little Stone elongated Stone flat
stone that came into our solar system
and he was one of the first to say that
it came out of the uh solar system maybe
from another galaxy and that maybe it
was a piece of some artificial artifact
and that it kind of indicates that there
are
et's out there that maybe are trying to
even communicate to communicate with us
okay so so this is one of the issues
that's how it started but then uh uh I
think it was a couple months back they
found some spherials uh I think it was
in a Pacific I can't remember now
exactly where and this is uh what they
think they are they one guy thinks it's
a dino killer the one or something
similar to the one to an asteroid that
killed the dinos and that maybe it was
artificial okay and the important thing
here is what uh that first line there it
says it would be among the most
extraordinary discoveries in scientific
history fragments of an alien spacecraft
from another solar system that landed on
Earth and
um well it would be an extraordinary
Discovery but science is not about
discovering America you know like
Columbus did science is about explaining
you have to explain something otherwise
you're not a scientist these people
confuse discovering and simply
describing uh for Science and that ain't
so and so it says uh analysis of the
spirulis composition proves they came
from where beyond the solar system okay
so some rocks that came from outside the
solar system but he takes it one step
further and suggests insinuates that
these sperials are actually uh uh
artificial okay and I guess you know
what that means means ETS you know some
people are trying to communicate with us
or send them over for who knows what
reason and uh so some scientists around
the world have tweeted his claim uh that
he found alien artifact with a lot of
skepticism okay and so yeah
um he's trying to push this at all costs
uh he every anything he finds out there
he and immediately uh identifies as E.T
and intelligent life and someone trying
to communicate with us he's into that
and he's a professor of Harvard and
that's why it's a little dangerous
because of all the
um influence that he has all the power
he has simply by his authority another
reason why you should reject out 30 in
um in science no no such thing as out 30
and no such thing as description or
Discovery okay we don't discover
anything in science in science we
explain okay and that's where the
problem starts okay and so this is some
of the opinions that people had uh on
about him these are some astrophysicists
pulled out four of them out of an
article
and so they all believe that you know or
some of them believe that uh yeah they
could be outside of the solar system
others believe it could be artificial
they all give that possibility and um
and some say like Martin Reese there
says uh he doesn't agree with that at
all he doesn't think uh uh it's
um
you know artificial
okay he he questions that he realizes
what Lube's trying to do he's just
trying to get this uh pet peeve you know
into the public eye so that he can
become famous and make money and who
knows what
okay and you can see some of the
comments there uh one fellow says and
all these are astrophysicists by the way
uh first one there Phil Sutton says I
don't think you can rule out that it
could be an alien spacecraft or an
object similar to what wiped out the
dinosaurs hit a planet another star
system sent some material out what if
another civilization found us before we
found them and sent probes out
and you wonder these people are
scientists you know and they have these
uh ideas about you know how the universe
works and what's out there
so these people are totally lost another
one Monica Grady uh says looks where it
could not is not sufficiently convincing
to say the metal particles definitely
from a meteorite let alone an alien
spaceship uh could be from a supernova
exploding star
and uh could have been made on Earth as
a side effect of nuclear weapons testing
because it was found near a nuclear site
okay or where they do some
yeah Atomic work you know and another
one says it is uh credible that they
have a unique extra solar composition
the discovery has Merit scientifically
does it but is being cheap and then
undermined by claims of alien technology
well the problem with all these comments
is that they have nothing at all to do
with science that's the problem with it
science is about explaining not about
discovering even if we discovered an
alien spaceship landing on top of the
Hawaii house it would not have anything
to do with science okay or or you can
say the scientific part would be if
anything uh explaining something about
it about that event but if you just say
look we discovered America we discovered
a chair I discovered a wall I bumped
into it that's not science
okay so we have to we have to keep in
mind what science is and these people
have the wrong notion of science
so let's look at this uh what is a
scientific method what is it about and
how does it compare to what these people
do
well what uh scientific method is not is
evidence
proof persuade and convince which is
what all these people are trying to do
they're saying look I'm going to
convince you that this thing came
outside a solar system okay and that
it's a
some some will say well yeah it's just a
rock and the others will say it's
artificial but other than that uh
they're all anyways in the wrong boat
they're all talking about evidence proof
and persuasion convincing people that's
got absolutely uh nothing to do with
science then you have here the uh real
scientific method and it's assumption
you make an assumption to understand the
theory you make an assumption you say
let us assume God exists that's an
assumption okay and then you explain
your theory you know you say uh this is
how God created the universe okay no
problem then it's uh consistent you have
an assumption you make an assumption
that God exists and everybody should
understand that uh has uh is an object
with location and then you proceed with
your theory and say this is how God made
the universe you know he put in his
assembly line built this this and that
no problem he explained How the Universe
was made according to his way of
thinking this this presenter okay and
these people don't do that they say let
me convince you let me convince you that
this came out of the solar system let me
convince you let me persuade and recruit
you to my way of thinking that uh this
was uh created by artificial
intelligence okay so no uh we have the
wrong scientific method in the minds of
all these people and this is what they
pass on to the next Generation from
generation to generation okay so this is
the problem
okay so here's the mathematical method
and this is how uh this Abby Lube is
this is what he's trying to do okay you
can see it here okay uh here's the
mathematical method you see a bee flying
around a flower you conclude that such
symbiotic Perfection could only be
accomplished by an intelligent designer
this proves that God exists
straightforward okay this is what he's
trying to do he's saying look I saw the
bee flying around the flower what else
could it be if not God
okay who created this perfection
and likewise the this uh lab is doing
the same thing he's trying to persuade
the crowd that his careful studies prove
that The Sparrows came out of another
galaxy
but having established his first proof
right his initial proof he moves on to
another proof he attempts to persuade
the throng that spherials are artificial
meaning that some intelligent ETS made
it so he went from evidence to proof and
then used that as uh further Evidence or
as an assumption to for a further proof
so he's just doing proof and evidence
that's all he's doing he's doing
persuasion uh and convincing at no point
did he do any science okay he just
giving he's just giving us his opinion
and he's trying to shove it down your
throat that's what they consider science
okay
and this is the real problem the problem
is the notion that these people have of
Science and the one that they spread in
the universities to the new generations
and they've been doing this for decades
now okay
okay uh to top it off you know since
this subject is so popular turns out
that there were some issues uh where
Congress held a hearing on ETS
especially on you know unidentified
flying objects and they wanted to get to
the bottom of it as a result apparently
someone gave the order and uh this is
what they've done you know the Pentagon
releases a new website uh where they're
gonna put all the UFO UFOs you know the
um the uh
uh photographs and whatever they have on
unidentified flying objects that they've
collected over the years okay so you can
go to that site and and see that and I
think what's going to happen here is
that uh you know people are still going
to have doubts they're gonna say well
you didn't put everything out there you
just put the stuff to convince us that
you know nothing about extra Terrell
still at extraterrestrial aliens
and this is the problem you you'll never
be able to convince those people because
the person who's got it in his mind
that uh ETS are here and that they built
the pyramids and who knows what else
um you're never going to convince them
you know they're just going to insist
that oh you're hiding something and uh
you know the uh there's no hoax
regarding ETS it's uh you know the crop
circles and all this stuff oh that's
real it's done by ETS and the government
knows it but they don't want to tell us
and now they put this site and they're
just trying to convince us with this
fake evidence or a little evidence that
they have they just put it out there to
please the crowds but the real evidence
they're hiding it over there you know in
Washington very uh closely guarded okay
so this is how these people think and I
don't think you're gonna ever be able to
convince them
okay that's that's my thought on that uh
just in case uh like if if you missed
something uh here you have the ETC
Exeter uh UFO Festival uh turns out
there was an incident at Exeter uh I
don't even know where this is uh
somewhere I think Connecticut or
Massachusetts somewhere up there I
didn't check anyways uh they have this
um uh celebration
because there was a sighting in 1965 and
there you can see the newspaper uh what
they uh were talking about you know how
how it became news in those days and
they said they saw a red light flying
object great red lighted flying object
and uh because of this uh you know now
they have this festival and you have
even people speaking so-called experts
says to talk Bigfoot UFOs and preparing
life for for uh preparing for life with
ETS okay so as you can see uh you know
these people are uh a lot of people are
into this
and some people making big money on this
or at least they they uh try to talking
about stuff like this like you know
Bigfoot and uh ETS and you know that man
didn't go to the moon and uh that the
Earth is flat and who knows what else a
lot of it's a it's a cottage industry
with uh all these people who you know
essentially uh you know disagree with
the government or believe that the
government is hiding something and they
have uh all these Shadows that are
following them you know
I don't know how they sleep at night
okay and just in case you know that uh
followed up uh uh Exeter came after this
Roswell that most people are more
familiar with and that's happened in
1947. uh this came out of the Wikipedia
it says uh that uh recovery metallic
rubber debris from a military Balloon by
Roswell Army Airfield and
um the press release announcing
possession of a flying disc decades
later conspiracy theories claimed that
debris from the alien spaceship have
been covered up by the government in
response that in 1994 the U.S uh Air
Force published a report concluding the
crashed object was a top secret nuclear
test surveillance uh balloon from
Project mcgul okay great so uh people
won't believe that and they'll say no no
it was a flying saucer he came from
outer space you know so it makes you
wonder about all these people there's
there's no way you're ever going to
convince him he who wants to believe
just believes without any reason they
don't even try to explain it they just
believe it okay and so what what can I
give you as my conclusions okay uh
regarding all these et's uh said a
couple of times uh these conclusions but
here I summarize them humans have the
highest level of intense that father
Universe can conceive or Grant or
concede uh there is no higher
intelligence in the entire universe than
what we have in our brains and I don't
know what kind of intelligence people
expect those who believe in super
intelligence maybe their mothers did not
give them enough intelligence and
they're complaining about that but no
Mother Nature has run ran out of gifts
to give us we are the highest
intelligence possible in the universe
it'll never get better than humans
anywhere in the universe anywhere in
time okay if there's human level
intelligence somewhere in the universe
it looks like us okay uh I'd like to say
that intelligence of our level right
descends from the trees okay you will
not see lions that are intelligent as us
you will not see Fish you will not see
birds okay it's got to be something like
us it's got to be a monkey it can't be
anything else it's got to be a
four-legged two two bipedal
uh monkey it can't be a four-legged you
know uh quadruple pedal okay
humans cannot travel to another star and
never will there's no way we can make it
to the nearest star and let alone to I
don't even think we'll ever make it to
Pluto or places like that we might might
if time allows make it to Mars I even
doubt that but it could happen you know
that's a possibility I think we can send
probes to Mars unmanned probes we can
probably send robots there but another
thing is to send a human you know you
got to train a lot you gotta study a lot
you know uh gravity and time away from
base and so there's a lot of issues to
be dealt with you know uh when when
you're sending someone as far away as
Mars and that's the nearest Planet
almost you know I think it's
um the second nearest planet after Venus
so
um you know uh we're never gonna go to
another star we might make it to Mars at
best the chances of human space rep
reaching a human level civilization are
next to nil and I'm not talking about
manned spacecraft that's impossible but
uh we can send a space trap like you he
got the two Pioneers 10 and 11 going out
of the solar system uh what are their
chances of ever being spotted by another
civilization
and my answer is none and I'm being kind
um or unkind really I should say next to
Nanda so I'm not so absolute but I think
it's closer to none than to Next To None
okay uh that's my honest opinion there
okay why distance is forbidding okay the
distances are impossible that's one
issue but even worse is time time is
staggered uh for different civilizations
and so when we you know we live what
last 200 years that's when we had
Electronics when we developed
Electronics let's concede the two full
200 years even though that's not true
either we we didn't really have
sophisticated devices until the 20th
century so we can just say that it's
been a hundred years but let's concede
200 years 200 years is a drop of water
even less than a drop of water in the
ocean of the universe in both
um uh space really under one hand but in
time in terms of time and so here you
have 200 years then we go extinct okay
because we're about to become extinct
and uh this is going to happen to any
civilization like us any humans like us
that live elsewhere which is already
quite scarce and for our spaceship to
reach that their neighborhood one not
crash against anything by the time you
get there and to hit it in those 200
years in which they have developed their
uh
um technology to be able to spot these
things
you know the the chances are zip
so uh we shouldn't send them out to talk
to someone besides we'll never figure it
will never find out whether someone
really saw it anyways but I don't think
that'll ever happen anyways that uh the
probe arrives at another place that is
seen by another group of human
civilization with intelligence to spot
it and then it happens to land you know
in someone's backyard or whatever
what are the chances of all that it's
it's zip it's absolutely Zen more than
likely those probes are going to crash
against something somewhere fall into
some sun some star and that'll be the
end of it so no and now let's look at it
in reverse someone sent something out
from you know some other planet well the
first thing is they they would have to
more or less uh live around the same
time as us in other words
um by the time the probe gets to us
their their spaceship gets to us they're
gone but it should arrive you know by
the time we live in those 200 years
and that you know that we developed
electronic electromagnetic technology
and the issue is what are the chances of
that you know how many probes are there
going out there coming in our Direction
and again my answer is none
let's move on to uh another subject
talked about The Ether and I do want to
make sure that we uh dot all the eyes
and cross all the T's or cross all the
eyes and Dot all the t's whichever one
right
and uh so uh what do we say well we say
The Ether is a bunch of particles that's
what I've told them and uh he did not
like that and no etheris likes that in
fact all the people who vouch for The
Ether never figured out what the ether
is okay and so the question is where
does the word ether come from you know
and so this is uh
um what the fellow said he said either
it cannot be a bunch of particles
okay and this is more or less what all
the etherists that have come here to
debate say the same exact thing they say
it ain't what you're saying bill
okay it ain't particles I know it's
particles it's always been particles but
these people have another notion of what
the ether is and so you try to pull
their tongue pull their brain whichever
one to try to find out what has do they
have going through their minds what are
they thinking about when someone
mentions the word ether what's going
through their minds so fellow first says
no it's not a bunch of particles okay
great uh the reason why the ether cannot
be made of particles is very simple
what's the stuff between the atoms
keeping a bunch of part uh atoms
together to form an object
aha
and uh he he answered his own question
there why The Ether can't be yeah The
Ether can't be because of that because
you know you cannot you have to have
something between any two particles and
if you don't have something there how do
they interact especially pull
you know uh entanglement gravity any
pull even if we concede it you know
gluons pulling two quarks together it's
always pull
and the only four set no ether is on
planet Earth ever was able to answer the
word the force of pull and this is this
is where they fail they cannot answer
the force of pull no one can produce a
uh pull unless they put something
between two objects
period there there's no possibility and
so they all try to pull they all try to
produce pull through push you know uh uh
Casimir type or less age type
um mechanisms uh where you remove what's
between two particles and the ones on
the outside push them towards each other
that's the notion of pull but they
cannot produce pull because for that you
need an elongated object that somehow
physically binds any two particles and
of course since they can't see or touch
anything there they said there's nothing
there and so they're going to do it
through push push is the only mechanism
they ever were able to explain they have
never been able to explain Paul and so
he says a magnetic field cannot be made
of discrete particle absolutely you're
totally right there and I'm I'm on your
side there again you can't have gaps
same for Gravity if you have gaps then
magic is responsible for the interaction
absolutely simple as that totally in
agreement that's why the ether can't be
because ether is a bunch of particles
but this fellow has a different uh
notion of what uh The Ether is and this
is more or less I guess uh where it
comes from
um
let me get this rid of this one here
and it's a web good old Air oh
well I got the wrong one out anyways uh
it's what the what the uh Greeks thought
of The Ether and it was that uh in the
old days in the days of the Greeks they
thought the ether was air ether means
air is another word for air it's just
the air of the Gods and what do you
think they thought of the air well they
thought of the air as particles and even
to this day people think of air as
particle we call them atoms we call them
molecules but what is air air is
molecules and The Ether was just uh some
other type of particles that we could
not see or touch but it was the motion
of those particles especially in a wavy
motion that they studied throughout the
19th century thinking that a wave of
light consisted of particles of discrete
particles you know waving up and down
oscillating that's what they all thought
what do you what did you think the ether
was when they when they talked about the
waves of light they thought it was the
wave of light was made up
you know and they uh did it
mathematically they said it's a bunch of
vectors uh electro electrophyll magnetic
field uh that's essentially what they
concluded but what do you think they had
in mind why do you think they uh what do
you think Michaels and Morty were
testing well they were testing to see if
there were particles gazillions of
particles and they wanted to see if the
Earth was going against that ocean of
particles and if there was a difference
in the speed of light Etc okay so they
always thought of particles
and these people say no it's not
particles Bill okay
so um yeah we have space okay
very dark very nothingness okay so we
call that space and now we're gonna put
some ether in there okay it looks like
this
okay and that's the ether a bunch of
particles that's what they always
thought okay that's that's uh the way
they always pictured it okay
okay so here we have the universe okay
and uh
pretty static because you know so far
away we don't really see things moving
you know they're so far away that we we
really see everything kind of static out
there the uh firmament as it used to be
called
and uh here it is the universe with
particles okay with these uh ether
particles and everything is made out of
these particles uh not only the unit not
only the uh objects such as the um uh
galaxies and stars and so on but also
the space in between them everything is
particles that's the way everybody's
always seen this uh nothing has changed
in the last 10 000 years even those
people who say the ethers not particles
what do you think they propose well they
don't even realize they're proposing
particles and in fact it happened to
this um fellow he says the following he
says uh this is what he proposes he says
I'm saying either is a continuous fluid
and I already told them that you know
flute is made of particles
you know because that's what fluid is
it's a substance that is made in fact he
put the definition there he's substance
right such as a liquid or gas that can
flow okay but what is he saying it's a
liquid or a gas what is a liquid or a
gas made of atoms made out of discrete
particles that's where it can flow so if
you're going to use the word fluid you
got to relate it to how the flu the word
fluid is defined otherwise you got to
define the word fluid in a different way
okay substance that easily changes its
shape yeah he hasn't said anything uh
capable of flowing changing relatively
shifting not rigid you so you can't say
that uh ether is a fluid because the
word uh fluid is a verb
not a noun okay so you can't say ether
is a fluid right fluid means is what
ether does if anything
okay so you haven't told us what the
ether is you're just telling it what it
does it's it flows that's all you're
saying and with that you haven't told us
anything because we still don't know
what the ether is you have to point to
The Ether first static before it moves
then you can make it flow and fluid and
whatever you want but first you got to
point to it stay you know uh in a static
mode
you know you don't point to a running
lion or a galloping horse you point to
the horse and say horse
and now I'm gonna make the horse gallop
and that's going to be a galloping horse
and now you see the horse Galloping so
we can understand we can follow your
train of thought first you point to The
Ether then you have a The Ether flow or
be fluid or whatever
yes a fluid often refers to liquids and
gases yeah in fact it does only refer to
that okay so are you saying the ether is
a liquid or a gas
made out of atoms and if it's not made
out of atom well you got a lot to
explain okay you can't just say it's a
fluid at least those are the ones we
know the most yeah it's the only ones we
know you know you can also say that
um uh you know when you ionize gas
becomes plasma but plasma is not an
object plasma is moving gas okay you've
got something moving it's called
ionization okay so something is
happening happening is a verb okay so so
plasma includes the object and the
motion you can't get rid of emotion from
plasma but there is absolutely it's like
you know the word uh the dead cat you
know no such thing in science in physics
physics there's only a cat
that is what he does and alive is what
he does but the object is called cat
only cat no dead cat no brown cat no
yellow cat no jumping cat just cat
yes a fluid often refers to liquid but
there is absolutely no reason why the
ether can't be a fluid well yeah okay so
it's a fluid all you told us is what the
ether does you haven't told us what it
is but you're saying it can't be meaning
what it is so you don't understand you
don't understand that fluid is a verb
not a not a noun
include is a category of things that
flow
okay it could be gas this could be
liquids so when you say ether is some
kind of fluid you just put it under a
category of things that flow and still
you haven't told us what the ether is
you haven't pointed to The Ether that's
why we need a picture
if you absolutely insist I'll draw you a
blob of ether okay and then you see like
you you can you know point to water you
can point to oil you can point to
molasses right you can put into all
these fluids right all these liquids
right but at least I can point and say
okay I know what molasses is looks like
that oil is that what is that okay the
fact that they're fluid it doesn't mean
that um
that um you've shown what it is yet I
mean are you saying that ether is
molasses why not I mean so far I'm
pointing to it so I'll point for you
I'll say you're saying that ether is
molasses and if you say no you haven't
you gotta the the onus is on you to tell
me what it is in the alternative if it's
not molasses
okay so that's the way it works in
science you have to tell the crowd don't
expect the crowd to tell you what the
ether is because I'm going to tell you
what the ether is a bunch of particles
that's what it is when it's always been
you don't like it then you got to put
something there for us to see and say
look this is The Ether if you think
ether is a an object and he says it's a
blob okay
okay uh but here is the um
uh some of the problems with what he's
saying he's saying it's a continuous
fluid continuous in physics means made
of a single piece
okay that's what continuous means and
it's the opposite of what the Greeks
thought of continues uh Aristotle very
clearly states that continuous means
that you can break it into pieces it's
made of parts so it's the opposite of
what continues is in physics which is
made of a single piece not made of parts
that's what continuous means so The
Ether this vowel says it's made of a
single piece
and it's fluid so I don't know what he's
talking about is he talking about rubber
or what is it you know how can it be
made of a single piece and be fluid and
yet this is how we look at the single
thread in under the Rope model it's
continuous and it's fluid in fact the
single thread contains all the
properties of solids gases and liquids
and in fact that's why we have solids
gases and liquids because a single
thread
um contains all these properties within
it okay it has that ability uh but fluid
is a noun a noun plus a verb okay you
can't have uh something called fluid
there's no physical object Standalone
object called fluid okay fluid is a noun
that does something verb so fluid is not
a thing a substance or an object fluid
is what a thing does okay it's a verb
it's just like plasma plasma is a noun
plus a verb okay plasma does not you
can't point to plasma
plasma ball in the plasma in it now what
you're pointing to is a verb something
is happening inside the plasma ball if
it's standing still it's called gas not
plasma if for it to be plasma it's got
to be moving it's got to be
ionizing that's what plasma is ionized
gas without that ionized it's not plasma
it's called gas okay and I don't know if
you understood that uh wind again
another uh wind is not a thing
got a physical object okay when it
already involves or in invokes or
embodies motion it's moving air okay
field same thing any kind of field you
want uh you want gravitational field or
magnetic field no problem electric field
um it's the it's the difference between
forest and many trees okay
okay
um uh forest in many trees are the same
same but uh you're treating field as if
it were one tree or if the forest or a
single object and that's not the case
field is like a forest and it means many
values that's what it is and likewise
The Ether means many core puzzles that's
what the ether always has meant but um
uh apparently this fellow thinks it's a
blob okay so what do we do well since he
hasn't done it I'm gonna do it for him
okay we're gonna make ether a block just
like you said we're gonna try to follow
what he tried what he what he described
okay that's all I can do okay so here it
is I showed this last time we have the
astronaut and he releases a blob of some
kind of liquid some kind of fluid in
space you can call it water if you want
even though it's kind of greenish but
we'll call it water no problem okay so
we got that
um
uh and here we have uh the blob up from
so we can see it much better okay and
there you see it okay and what's the
issue the issue with this now you have
to explain light and gravity with that
blob
okay
and uh so here's uh what you gotta
explain here is light okay you gotta
explain uh uh waves of light inside The
Ether if that's what you think light is
otherwise you got to explain light in
some kind of way and all I can do is put
what uh people always have thought that
light is the vibration of The Ether and
that's what I'm showing there if you
don't agree with that no problem uh you
have to tell us what you think light is
in your blob or under your blob or
outside your blob or whatever aside from
the fact you get to tell us what the
black stuff is that gives shape to your
blob because if you're going to talk
about a blob there's something outside
of it and you have to identify that blob
in other words that black stuff in other
words what you got to tell us is
um uh if the blob has shape and
hopefully it does if you're going to
talk about a blob then you got to tell
us what's uh what it's in what is within
with it in other words uh the black
stuff is that space is the blood up
contained within space and what is space
then you know because a lot of people
identify the ether with space in other
words a lot of people think that space
and ether are synonyms
there is no such thing as ether and
space they're both the same thing other
people think that ether is within space
okay and that's fine but then you got to
tell us what space is okay you can't
just say it's within space because we
don't know what space is yet in in your
theory your hypothesis your way of
thinking okay
okay so uh here let's put the blob uh
let's uh
freeze it okay there you have it frozen
blob okay in fact we'll go a step
further and we'll put it on white so
that we can see it really well okay and
again uh those who proposed a blob have
to tell us what the white stuff is in
this case right no problem but you you
got to identify every object in in our
field of view you got to tell us what
the white stuff is if the blob is ether
okay so far so good I hope you can
follow along I'm gonna try to be as
slowly as possible so that everybody can
follow along okay okay so we gotta
explain gravity among we you have to
explain light that's one issue but now
we have to explain gravity and
um here's I'm going to put a scenario
okay here we have a little spoon that
falls to the floor okay and if you don't
believe spoons fall to the floor go to
your home go to your kitchen take a
spoon let go of it and you'll find out
it under normal conditions it'll fall to
the floor we call that process whatever
is doing all that that whole thing we
call that whole phenomenon we call it
gravity okay okay so now what we're
gonna do we're gonna freeze the uh spoon
in mid-air okay
so far so good uh it's gonna fall down
but we just feed froze one frame so that
we can explain the following we're gonna
go in there now and we're gonna use the
blob
okay is the blob pushing
on the spoon that's one of the things
one of the possibilities okay
um if you think a blob is pushing on the
spoon you got to tell us why and how it
does it you know what the cause is you
know why does the blob go downwards
instead of upwards for example you know
if this is the way you visualize it okay
again uh I don't I'm not putting words
in anybody's mouth I'm just saying this
is one of the scenarios you got to
explain if you think ether is a blob
okay here's another one okay
this time it's below because the blob is
gonna pull on the uh spoon you gotta
explain to the crowd how it is that the
um you know that the blob pulls on the
on the spoon why does it pull uh why is
it going downwards why does it go up
where where does it push from the bottom
upwards for example you know and all
these things you gotta you gotta really
Analyze That to death okay if that's if
that's what you think the ether is a
little blob that's pulling or pushing
okay now the important thing here that
I'm I want you to focus on because I'm
sure he's going to reject these two
scenarios right and a lot of etherists
will as well uh they're saying Bill uh
you're treating the little blob uh
that's that's not our ether our ether is
the entire universe in other words The
Ether covers uh all of space the whole
universe or whatever right okay the
reason I put these two scenarios down
and showed them here Illustrated them is
because I don't want them to say that
there's a portion of the ether that
pushes or pulls the uh the spoon down in
other we'll call this the little blob
okay we'll call it the little blob the
little blob either pushes or pulls on
the um on the spoon upwards or downwards
okay we'll call that the little blob now
let's go with the Big Blob which is what
these people usually think of when they
say ether okay here's the Big Blob okay
now okay here we have the Earth we have
the spoon falling to Earth and you can
see the blob I have uh expanded it
greatly and we will assume that the blob
that covers the entire Earth it
stretches all the way to the ends of you
know all the way to hell
okay so now we have uh the little uh
spoon falling and again if ether is the
entire ocean the entire blob that covers
the entire universe you have to explain
how this blob moves the spoon downwards
in one region of the universe in this
case space in this case your home your
floor your house right so you gotta
explain how the the whole ocean does
this
and uh just in case here's the uh one
coming from below as well and remember
someone uh you're in the North Pole and
the other guy's in the South Pole and so
your spoon is Falling Towards the center
of the earth this spoon is Falling
Towards the center of the earth so it's
going in the opposite direction as yours
and you gotta explain how your blob does
this and again uh we're we're asking you
to explain how the entire ocean does
this okay you cannot select a little
piece of the ocean and say look my
little ether here does this now you
either talk about the ocean or you talk
about water you either talk about the
forest or you talk about one tree you
either talk about children or you talk
about child or you talk about you know
people and you talk about man
you can't use the ether in both ways you
can't say the ether is the entire ocean
and The Ether also in this little region
of The Ether does this
okay I hope you understood the issue the
issue is you cannot use the ethers both
forest and tree okay which is what these
people usually try to do they say look
uh The Ether is the entire ocean it's
this blob that fills all of space right
so either the entire ocean then don't
tell me the ether over here pushed you
know here we have a spoon
little spoon and we're gonna let go of
it
and I say how did that happen you said
The Ether did
well the ether's the entire ocean how
did the entire ocean of the entire
universe fill in the all of space all of
space time all the way to the ends of
the Mind Right how did it do that
okay then and again if it pushes it down
here how did it also push the spoon on
the other side of the planet in the
opposite direction
okay so you gotta explain those two
things right
okay and here let me give you another
scenario similar to that here's a little
fish and we have that little fish in the
ocean and here you can see the blob is
covering the entire Earth so the Earth
is inside the ether inside the blob
right and we have a little fish within
one of the oceans Pacific Ocean in this
case within the Earth okay so now we're
going to look at the little fish inside
the ocean here he is okay and he's
Falling Towards the center of the earth
for some reason something is pulling the
fish down maybe it's a Whirlpool maybe
something is sucking it downwards the
fish can't help he falls okay so he
can't avoid it here we see him in a
little more uh
um you know
blown up a little bit so that we can see
the fish going down okay so the question
is the fish is going down you cannot say
the ocean did it
okay in the best of cases you can say
the local water somehow you know there
was a current or something that pushed
him down but what is irrational is to
say the ocean
puts push the fish downwards okay
because uh you would have to explain
that process how the whole ocean you
know whole Pacific Ocean pushed that
little fishy down towards the center we
don't usually talk like that we don't
say that you know the ocean pushed the
fish down you can say that a current did
or maybe there was a I don't know some
uh
Whirlpool that put pulled on the on the
uh you can you can do that you know but
you got to talk about whirlpool and not
about Ocean and the same way with either
you cannot talk about The Ether doing
gravity if if you're gonna say that the
ether is the entire ocean okay because
otherwise if you're gonna use The Ether
uh and the little blob then you gotta
explain how the little blob pushes in a
little blob pulls
now you got to go to that scenario then
you know I did not uh put words in your
mouth I'm just saying that if you're
gonna treat the blob as a portion of the
blob
then then we forget about the Big Blob
and you got to look at the little blob
and how that little blob you know pushes
the spoon down or pulls it uh From Below
okay so you either talk about the ethers
the whole thing the whole Ocean or you
use some other word to refer to the
little blob or the big or pushing or
pulling in other words that's the
homework if you want to take take it and
uh I want to resolve it those are the
issues those are the questions I hope
you understood them all otherwise look
at the video later on and figure it out
uh what it was all about
okay let's move on to another issue that
this same fellow I think uh raised and
um
it's got to do with uh this word Rey
now the only arrays I know are these uh
fish uh uh that are in the sea uh that
kind of Ray okay
um but here it is I think it's a fish I
don't even know if that's the case Okay
so uh
uh where'd he go
let me get this up here okay so fellow
says that young has never seen light
talking about uh uh young the uh what
was his name
Thomas Young uh who did the slit
experiment okay so he says he's never
saw away light waves
of course not if you would have seen
them uh be essential if anybody would
see waves uh be great in fact uh if you
can see a wave you can see a concept
such as wave boy you've got good eyes
you got better eyes than God it has
never been more than an assumption
exactly and that's what it always is
called an assumption in science in
physics so that's what a wave is it's an
assumption not not something to see or
touch it's an assumption good same for
JJ Thomson he never saw electron
particles okay and uh he said the
cathode ray tube experiment was freaking
rave
was a freaking ray what do you mean
array what is a ray
you know from one end of the tube to the
other and what do you think that Ray was
made of oh I don't know tell us why
didn't you tell us
and yeah uh JG Thompson did not see a
ray because like good old Ray there he
was blind he couldn't see that's why he
couldn't see the ray okay so we have to
look up this definition of the word gray
to find out what this poor fellow is
talking about okay and so here you have
it it is an idealized geometrical model
of light or other electromagnetic
radiation so it's an idealized geometric
uh object that's what it is so there is
no such thing as a ray it's just a a way
that you know that these people uh try
to talk and they say look that's a ray
what did you mean by array what that
means that uh there's something there
okay it's called a array and um
and so yeah it's just a geometric object
it's a straight line that's all it is
and that's what that's always been used
as so you can't use the word gray
because it's first of all it's a
mathematical or geometrical object uh
it's not even an object what it is is an
arrow that represents motion you start
at a and you move to Infinity that's all
array is so you can't use the words Rey
and say that uh light or electricity is
array okay
so um here we have uh the version uh
from uh the Rope model okay
and here it is
um
what is light that uh is on top of Ray
Charles there well light uh every one of
those Rays as you call them we say it's
a rope okay in fact uh it's not a single
rope you got gazillions of ropes there
per Ray okay because the Rope is such a
thing a thin uh object that uh we can't
see an atom much less uh a rope which is
much thinner than the radius of any atom
much much thinner so you're talking
about something that we can't see or
touch for that matter just like we can't
see the air we can't see a rope but
that's what those light rays beans are
you know what we're staring at is uh the
vibrations of
um the Rope going from Adam to atom
okay so what you're seeing here is Adam
to Adam and uh the ropes are
striking one atom and being relayed to
another atom all through the air and
that's why we can see all those that
light okay what you're seeing is really
the vibration of atoms and uh
electricity well electricity is at the
bottom okay and you talked about a
cathode ray tube CRT and uh that beam
that Ray as you called it well uh that's
a bunch of atoms actually molecules I
like to use the
um
because they're easier to explain but it
um it's easier to understand it with uh
with atoms because you just put hydrogen
atoms there and you merge them and you
say okay let's assume all these hydrogen
atoms are merged okay and then what you
have is counterclockwise and clockwise
rotation of that whole string of merged
electron shells and that's what we say
is electricity okay so so we do have an
explanation for the CRT the electricity
or current running from one plate to
another and of uh a light which is what
you see on the top and now the ball is
in your court you tell us what array is
and what you think it's made of and uh
if you're gonna put your blob in there
ether blob no problem explain to us uh
how The Blob does light how The Blob
does gravity and uh again like I
explained a minute ago you uh are
supposed to put the scenario where you
have this ocean and explain it with the
ocean and if you cannot explain with the
ocean if you're going to go to the
actual falling of the spoon for example
then you have to talk about the little
blob which is the first two scenarios I
showed where one pushes the other one
pulls and explain that so you decide
which one you want to go with okay
balls in your court
okay another fellow raised uh
another issue and this has to do with
the word shape and the word shape comes
from our definition of the word object
which is that which I shape very simple
that was the scientific definition that
everybody missed the last 10 000 years
no textbook of physics has that
definition no textbook of physic starts
with a definition of object although you
cannot do physics without an object okay
so that's the context okay so this vowel
says the following he says
um get them up here
same object is that which has shape is
absolutely absurd okay good object what
is an object an un an identifiable
collection of matter and he got that
from the Wikipedia says a physical
object or physical body is a collection
of matter visible or tangible surface
that's what they're they're suggesting
it is that's the notion these people
have but you look up the word matter and
it says any substance with mass takes up
space by having volume okay
and uh but then they continue to say
that does not include massless particles
so that's not a matter if it's massless
such as photons or other energy
phenomena or waves such as light or heat
okay so those are not matter okay so we
wonder what they are what is light uh is
it the ghost
what is the category for that and then
you look up the word substance because
that's how they Define matter it matters
any substance matter substances matter
that's how they Define substance so we
have matter of substance and substances
matter oh great we learned a lot
anything that has mass and takes up
space same thing as matter so you can't
use the word substant to define the word
matter because uh matter and substance
are synonyms but then we have the issue
of mass what is mass well that turns out
nobody in the last 10 000 years Define
the word mass here is the definition of
mass that you'll find uh at least in the
Wikipedia says intrinsic property of a
body it was traditionally believed to be
related to the quantity of matter in a
physical body until the discovery of the
atom and particle physics it was found
that different atoms and different
Elementary particles theoretically with
the same amount of matter have
nonetheless different masses
so okay they figured out that uh same
amount of matter different masses okay
great and it says here mass in modern
physics has multiple definitions which
are conceptually distinct so at no point
did they Define the word math they just
said what it ain't and what it ain't is
the quantity of matter okay so what is
mass well it says there one way to
distinguish conceptually between at
least seven different aspects of mass or
seven physical Notions that involve the
concept of mass okay so
um they've had they have seven Notions
of mass and I guess they picked the one
they want anytime they want to use it so
you know they they have their choice
there every experiment today has shown
these seven values to be proportional in
some cases equal
and it says there are a number of ways
Mass can be measured or operationally
defined well we don't care about
operationally defined because
um that's defining at the end of the of
the presentation we have to know in
advance before you operationally define
it uh what you mean by the word mass
that way we can follow your presentation
and what they want to do is uh they do
functional or operational definitions
meaning first let's run a test and
whatever comes out of that that's the
definition of mass for today tomorrow we
don't know that's the way they handle it
and so the people who said it really
correctly are wheeler and um
Taylor here and they said nature does
not offer us any concept as the amount
of matter history has struck down every
proposal to Define such a term even if
we could count number of atoms or by any
other counting method try to evaluate
amount of matter that number would not
equal Mass
so what did you learn today son in
school I learned very little uh
father because uh
nobody can tell me what mass is they
tell me what Mass ain't not what it is
and then they say there's different
kinds of masses okay great what is mass
before you tell us the differences
between them and they can't tell you of
course they can't and just in case what
was the other word volume here it is
they don't know what volume is either
volume is a measure of three-dimensional
space
well I didn't know space had three
dimensions uh space only has zero
Dimensions because space is nothing a
cube has three dimensions not space but
see they always mistake uh these words
they call it uh word salad you know they
don't like to deal with grammar and they
think that's uh something reserved for
English Majors or Librarians who knows
it says the volume of a container is the
capacity of the container okay and again
it says capacity of the amount uh
maximum amount of material that a
container can hold
that's in one one uh article in
Wikipedia another one says an object
that sinks displaces an amount of fluid
equal to the object's volume
so we got a problem either either uh
volume is what's inside the container or
volume is what the container pushed
aside when it was pushed inside the
water
okay so here you have the example of a
little uh bolt it was thrown in water
and that's how much money at this place
how much water it displaced and that's
known as volume but these people first
say that volume is the same thing as
capacity which is how much the test tube
holds as far as water is concerned so we
got a problem we don't know if volume is
on the inside of of the test tube or on
the outside of the test tube and they
have both they say it's both so we don't
know what mass is we don't know what
volume is okay because they have all
these different definitions and
different Notions they don't they don't
really pinpoint them they just leave it
like that and they say that's good
enough and they continue this is the
problem
okay so this same fellow then comes over
and says um
form is a three-dimensional geometric
figure such as a sphere cube cylinder
okay form exists in three dimensions
with height width and depth
death I didn't know death was a
dimension I mean where does poor fellow
study some Monastery or what
and yeah uh depth is uh like breath uh
our uh vectors and the only thing I want
to say about breath here is that you
know in in other languages they don't
have the word for breath at all you know
I found out that uh talking with
different people finally came to the uh
understanding that they don't have a
word for breath they sometimes use uh
amplitude that's the closest they've got
you know sideways uh
Direction but uh we're always when you
talk about death breath or elevation
you're talking about motion and for this
poor file to confuse it with the
dimension which is a static concept
whereas Vector is a dynamic concept it
means you know that uh he missed
important classes at the University if
he went to the university you're more
than likely you know he got all his
information from a monastery uh that's
probably where he studied okay yeah
breath is not a breath or Death Or Not
uh
uh Dimensions or coordinates for that
matter
they're vectors okay and uh this file
continued he said uh shape is
two-dimensional and four is
three-dimensional geometric figure
and uh the question is where did he get
this a lot of people have the same
misconception you know and uh you know
uh when we look them up and find out
what the definition of these words are
okay let's find out it says shape the
quality of a distinct object or body in
having an external surface or outline or
form or figure so they're talking about
an object or a body right and they're
just talking about the external surface
or outline okay so it could refer to the
outline or the external surface surface
is a three-dimensional term okay surface
refers to a three-dimensional object
only three-dimensional objects have
surface
um
two-dimensional uh like uh you know
planes and so on they don't have surface
that's not called a surface they're
called planes okay and this quality is
found in some object or body right and
it says its form okay outline silhouette
and then when you look at form it says
external appearance of a clearly defined
area as they change from color or
material configuration a triangular form
and it says the shape of a thing or
person something that gives or
determines shape a mold
so um this notion that this fellow has
that shape and form are somehow
different you know is uh is uncalled or
unwarranted yeah unjustified he never
Justified that at all okay and just in
case in in different languages I can
only tell you the ones that uh either
either speak or studied or familiar with
which are the first uh seven there and
uh you know in Spanish Uh Russian form
uh German French Portuguese and Italian
uh essentially they don't have a word
shape they use the word form for
everything
there is no difference between shape and
form and as you can see from the
definition shape and form our synonyms
and there is no difference between shape
and form now some people want to use the
word shape to refer to a 2d and form to
refer to 3D that's her personal
prerogative but there's nothing in the
definitions that shows that okay and
then you can see other languages there
the same thing they only have the word
form in almost every language okay so
there is no such word as shape in other
languages
okay so they don't make a distinction
between shape and form one BN 2D and the
other one 3D they just call form to
everything that's the first issue okay
so
um here you have a 3D cube
well is it
looks like a 2d Cube to me because it's
on a you know flat platform flat uh
background okay so what I'm staring at
is really a 2d Cube there is no 3D now
it's the mind that gives uh projection
depth or uh length
uh latitude or whatever you want to call
it you know you have something here
where where you can see a projection
right well but it's because the mind
does that what's coming out of the
screen is not 3D what's coming out of
screen is objectively 2D and it's the
mind that pulls you into believing that
you're staring at something with
projection so um let's uh remove the
stuff that's bothering you that makes
you think that this is a 3D object here
it is okay that's what you were staring
at some of those lines were bothering
you okay
they were making you mistake
um uh what was coming at a screen
objectively which was 2D for a 3D object
simply because we put these lines on
there okay so it's the mind that does
that not what's coming out of the screen
objectively is what comes out of the
screen subjectively is what you have in
your mind okay and uh so the first thing
you I want to mention is that you know
the reason we say objects is that which
has shape is because even if it were 3D
even if you use form and it accepted as
3D the 3D includes the 2D so by using
the 2D shape as you you know as you want
to call it
um you're including all objects in the
universe includes anything that's 2D and
3D and there's no Zero D One D or a 4D
or above so uh by putting 2D you include
every object in the universe now if you
want to specify and say well that's a 3D
object and this is a 2d object no
problem yeah you can specify that later
but object that which has changed and
shape if it's 2D in your mind no problem
still covers the 3D because uh 3D
objects have shape also okay imagine uh
here's a lady and she's trying to give a
presentation and she says and this is uh
Schrodinger's cat before he died okay
and so the question here is you say oh
you can't present that in physics
because you're presenting a 2d object
that's not a 3D cat that's a 2d cat
and so if a person gives a presentation
they are not able to say this cat is an
object is a thing you say no it's not a
thing because it's 2D it has shape but
it doesn't have form
well obviously you're representing a cat
and just like you did with a cube you're
supposed to imagine right C
uh what's not on the screen what's on
the screen is 2D but your mind already
understands or is supposed to understand
that that cat is 3D
okay and the reason it's 2D only because
you had to bring a picture of the cat
snapshot you took of your own cat maybe
you know you brought that to the
presentation say look this is a cat
okay so uh if if we were to uh
differentiate it we would not be able to
give presentations uh using 2D images
because oh that's not physics no no
because you're saying you're making a
representation of something else I mean
I can show you this and say this is a
rope and uh but what do you see you see
2D because you've got a screen that's
pointing that out to you as a 2d object
okay it's the mind that said well I know
that's 3D partly because Bill is behind
the Rope okay but I can uh point to a
picture of a rope and say look rope are
you gonna think that that's 2D and
that's not acceptable in science or in
physics because it's 2D because it's
just an image it's a representation of a
rope
so obviously you know the word shape is
just fine even if it's even if in your
mind it's 2D which in ain't the world
over
everybody uses the word form and it's
the same thing as shape shape is just an
English word that means form okay I hope
that's taken care of and this person had
another issue and he said uh material
sphere form has a shape of a circle a
magnetic field has a shape of a circle
no no a magnetic field
shape whatsoever and let me prove it to
you proof there's evidence okay
Authority okay we go to the uh physics
stack exchange uh prominent site for
so-called physics mathematical physics
actually and what do they say they say
look all fields are really infinite okay
the magnetic field decreases where the
square of the distance magnetic field
You Know Field decreases with the square
of the distance it never ends
you move away from a current that
generates the field the same goes for a
static magnet etc etc and they put the
little infinity sign there so where does
the field end at Infinity it never ends
okay
and how about the uh in fact it says the
magnetic field in the same way as an
electric uh dipole field will vanish
where at Infinity
and how about the gravity uh field
gravitational field well same thing
gravity has infinite range the force of
gravity decreases one over r squared
that's slow enough for it to be felt
etcetera et cetera on the other side of
the universe
so how big is the gravitational field
how big is a uh
a electric field how big is a magnetic
field they are infinite conceptually
infinite they stretch out forever
okay so this notion that you have that a
field any field has shape uh you forget
to factor the definition of the word
field all fields are infinite and
whatever is infinite has no shape no
form okay because you you cannot see the
end of it you cannot see the edges of it
okay so uh please draw
0.2 a field that has shape and whatever
you point to I'm going to put some more
of those numbers there and show you that
it extends forever in any direction that
you wish to see it it's just that you do
not realize that your field extends
forever and so something extends forever
does not have shape and until you
understand that well you still haven't
taken kindergarten classes in physics
okay
let's move on to the subject matter
today which is
the conscious universe
conscious universe is the universe
conscious the the universe think is a
universe like God you know the
intelligent design uh
fall there with a brain that had a
purpose for us for the universe for
everything
maybe he's playing a little toy Game and
his uh in heaven you know a little toy
soldier he says I'm going to entertain
myself I'm going to create some humans
and some animals and some Earth and
whatever and I'm gonna watch what
happens you know and control it right
because you got to control you don't
want your experiment to get out of hand
right
anyways uh there are different Notions
of what this universe is and we saw a
couple of them uh last week here's the
notion we presented the other day uh the
electricians the electric Universe
primarily but there are others as well
and they believe that uh the universe uh
consists of all these things you know
plasma and electric currents and that
everything is done with magnetism and so
on so they have these Notions they like
to Tinker with gadgets such as
oscilloscopes and amp meters voltmeters
and so on great they think the sun is uh
just a ball of Plasma on the outside and
that that's where the heat is generated
is not generated in the center of the
sun okay then you have on the other side
uh mathematical physics primarily the
relatives when it comes to uh the cosmos
the uh you know the Big World the world
of the Big K A believe in black holes
and wormholes and uh the W maps
and the uh you know uh space time and
dark matter and all this good stuff so
this is their world and you can see that
they don't match that's why they don't
like each other okay uh the folks on
director relatives they they're more
powerful they have control of the
strings of information and so they press
the other guys down with their thumb
they say I'm gonna squash you because I
have the power okay
okay so uh what is this universe like uh
for all these people in fact it doesn't
matter whether it's the electricians or
the etheris or the
establishment they all this is what they
propose that whether they know it or not
this is the only thing that's ever been
proposed in the last 10 000 years okay
here it is
particles this is all they understand
this is all they ever done
it's called The Ether in one in one
religion another religion calls it the
false vacuum another religion calls it
space-time it's all the same thing okay
no one's ever done anything different
than this particles many particles this
is the only proposal we ever had on the
table okay
so this is our starting point and um
and so there are other people that say
well there's a little more than that
than particles
then uh you know coordinates and uh
dimensions and vectors uh values there's
something else
that is not really measurable
it's called conscience or being
Consciousness okay that's what it is and
this goes you know a long ways back uh
in history you know here you had one of
the famous guys who proposed this his
name was the Buddha Gautama right and
the budo taught that everything is
connected and that everything is
constantly changing
now that's a little different than the
particles you just saw because the
particles you know they're not connected
and here these people are saying
everything is connected okay so are they
talking physics or are they talking
poetry what are they talking here
and it says these fundamental
observations of the world are shared by
ecology and evolution and that's the
site there you can look it up another
site uh file writes uh a little paper
says there can be no first cause and no
creation X nielo of the universe as in
The Big Bang Theory since the universe
has neither beginning nor end the only
Universe compatible with Buddhism is a
cyclic one okay de Buddhism the
exquisitely precise fine-tuning of the
universe for the emergence of life and
Consciousness as expressed in the
anthropic principle is not due to a
creative principle but to the
interdependence of matter with flows of
of what
Consciousness we have the flow of
Consciousness that too having coexisted
for all times so Consciousness not only
exists but Consciousness flows oh my God
I'm wondering what this guy is talking
about uh back to word salad
that's the little word sounded that uh
offends these people so much here it is
let's look at the definition of
Consciousness what the hell are they
talking about Consciousness it says
awareness when some other words after
that but essentially awareness what is
awareness a concept about knowing
perceiving and being cognizant of events
and that's more or less the notion that
everybody has of consciousness
so uh how can a concept exist in what
way does it exist and how does a concept
flow
okay so we got a problem there because
this Buddhist uh says that a concept not
only exists but flows and that's a
little different than the universe
created by the mathematicians which is a
world of particles where who knows how
they interact because you know they're
not connected they're not touching each
other all the particles are discrete you
know point in space time that's an event
and this event is separate from this
other event in any ways you can't
connect events because they're Concepts
so how are you going to kind of connect
them and so we have these problems they
put Concepts in there and then they say
well this concept's over here this
concept's over here and are they
connected no they're all independent but
then they say this concept meaning a
particle can affect that concept another
party go through entanglement
so how does it affect it by please
explain the mechanism and that's where
they put more Concepts in between and
they say well this concept affects that
concept through another concept so we're
a full of Concepts and we don't
understand squat because we can't
visualize the mechanism that's the issue
okay so here's one person who tries to
explain it in uh quora says all points
of space and time are connected
aha so they're connected I guess they're
not conducted by Consciousness like in
the case of Buddhism
means that everything in the universe is
connected in some way even when they are
separated by Massive distances or vast
amounts of time okay connected how what
connects them they just say this they're
connect
what do you mean by that I mean
connected well
reaction especially you're talking about
physics here you better have a physical
entity mediating or being serving as a
mediator and these people say they're
connected take it or leave it like it or
not I'm going to shove it down your
throat they're connected that's just a
statement they haven't Justified it this
connection is often referred to as the
fabric of space-time space time is a
concept not a fabric
okay fabric is uh you know this is a
fabric my my clothes that's a fabric
what it's made of but uh Space Jam is
not a fabric space time is known as a
concept time specifically hopefully
you'll understand the time is a concept
you cannot say that it's a fabric that
it's a thing and so you cannot say that
two particles are connected or two well
two particles first two corpuscles are
connected by time
that's not a connection okay
uh you might say one influence is the
other and you would have to explain how
but you cannot see the connected
connected is a physical term okay but
see they usually they they slide these
uh words they sneak them into physics
and they're connected well show me the
connection you know if they're connected
what is it a chain that connects them or
is it a rope is it a string cable you
know how are they connected wire you
know when we move we can feel the
space-time curvature around us oh yeah
how many drinks did you have
bartender I wanna I want whatever he had
so you can move you can move the you can
feel the space time I don't I feel the
air but not not space time this means
that events that happen in one part of
the universe can have an effect on
events that happen in another part of
the universe even if they are separated
by billions of light years okay but you
got to tell us
how they're connected how how one
affects the other physically that's what
we need to understand and here uh
another fellow follows up and says all
points in space and time are connected
means that you can draw a line between
any two such points no no draw a line is
not connected you still haven't because
until you draw your infinite line you
know uh so far we we have no connection
until you finish your line and since a
line is made of infinite points I guess
it's like uh Achilles and a tortoise you
know and never catch up
so you cannot say all points in time
mean that that are connected means that
you draw a line between them that's not
connected that's math that's not
connection
that's just like just that's just the
math exactly not all points have the
same kind of physical connection and
again it's not a physical connection
that you have been talking about for
instance there are trajectories in
space-time that are not possible
what does trajectory have to do with
connection so you cannot always get from
one point to another by obeying the laws
of physics okay I don't know what he's
talking about there there is a
metaphysical meaning about the spiritual
connectedness of everything yeah they
talk about spiritual connectedness not
about physical connectedness and they
can constantly confuse one with the
other they treat Consciousness as a
physical object as if it were a string
or something they say we're connected
we're connected by what by Consciousness
what do you mean by Consciousness yeah
it means that
um uh we all have these I guess
telepathy I don't know what they're
really referring to what do you mean
we're connected by consciousness what
kind of nonsense is that in physics I
mean if you want to talk poetry over
there you know and in a class no problem
talk about any or religion you know no
problem but if you're going to come into
physics and talk about connectedness
then you got a problem because no we're
not connected by Consciousness you can
be connected by a rope by a Wire by a
cable but not by Consciousness there's
no tell-up of the uh or telekinesis in
uh in physics okay no such monster
okay so um here's another fellow and
he's got a site and he says there is a
deeper connection they all talk about
Connection huh that unites all things in
the universe all things all objects
right and it can be observed in various
Realms from the physical to the
spiritual
okay let's look at the physical I don't
care about the spiritual and he says the
interconnectedness of all things is a
principle that suggests that everything
in the universe is interconnected and
interdependent by the way this is a
professional site where the guy has a
Quantum equation and he's that's what he
sells he's trying to convince people to
buy stuff that he can fix or he can
solve problems with his Quantum equation
and he says imagine a spider's web with
each strand representing a different
aspect of the universe each strand is
connected to every other strand and the
actions of one strand affect the entire
web okay so far so good I like this
because it looks like my theory here
this is similar to how everything in the
universe is connected and interdependent
okay no problem I can understand that
he's talking about a spider's web so
he's got all these little uh threads
right and uh all these strands are
connected to every other strand Etc okay
we all understand this no problem if he
if he can draw that or at least we can
picture what he's saying but that's not
what he's talking about he's talking
about something else he has the
principles of quantum mechanics and the
theory of general relativity demonstrate
that particles and forces are
interconnected at the side of atomic
level
particles and forces the particles are
wave function collapses and vibrations
of fields both Concepts and enforces our
Concepts as well so how do you connect
concepts with Concepts they're connected
by what okay so he's already got a
problem there because he's not making
any sense if he's going to bring Quantum
into this I mean he was doing fine when
he was talking about a spider's web but
as soon as he talks about Quantum
particles which aren't particles and
forces we cannot talk about
interconnectivity because connectivity
is a physical term and he's not talking
about physical he's talking about
Concepts this interconnectedness is not
only limited to the Physical Realm but
also in the emotional psychological and
spiritual Realms suddenly he uh goes on
a tangent Ryan he's talking about
emotions thoughts and actions right and
he says this interconnectedness can be
observed in the realm of Consciousness
oh my God one of those huh many
spiritual traditions and philosophical
teachings propose that we are all
connected in a what deeper sense okay
what's this deeper sense uh hopefully
something physical right that our
individual Consciousness is part of a
larger Collective Consciousness this
idea suggests that everything in the
universe is interconnected in a way that
is beyond the physical
and again you can see if they use the
word interconnected with Consciousness
and the spiritual they're talking about
feelings thoughts actions you know and
so uh now they're connecting verbs
and this is how they slide these words
in there and not only do these people do
it other people do it as well you know
um uh people who are into this
Consciousness stuff you know I detest
the word Consciousness especially when
they bring it into physics I never want
to hear that word never every time I
hear the word Consciousness or conscious
it drives me up the walls because I know
I'm talking to a
what do you call it idiot yeah
okay so here's one of the famous guys
who does Consciousness uh and introduces
it into physics or mathematical physics
okay his name is
and he said the world is profoundly
connected okay that he calls it the
connected Universe he's got a video on
that uh says our planet stars in
galaxies account for only 4.9 matter of
the universe he got that from The
Establishment okay so he's vouching for
the establishment establishment here
he's going to take a detour trying to
say that he discovered something new
right so what makes up the rest of the
universe okay and he says space space is
not empty space time at the quantum
level is fluctuating with an intense
energy level full of dynamic energy
components so we have space or space
time and it's full of energy whatever
energy is and what is energy energy is a
undefined word to this day they aren't
able to Define it or as Mr uh Richard
Feynman said he said we have no idea
what energy is
yeah because energy is not a thing it's
not a what
okay there's no such thing called energy
energy is a mathematical concept so to
say what is energy or you point to
energy you can't do that you can't draw
a picture of energy because it's a
concept any more than you can draw love
or or intelligence
everything is connected through this
energy so what does he propose as a
connection he proposes this mathematical
concept called Energy that's in the
space that actually it is the space that
creates matter
and uh
so he says space creates matter and
energy is within this space and it's
this energy that connects us
great we understood quite a bit
oh my God and I wonder what these people
drink you know I'd like to have a shot
of that I mean I'm just a regular guy I
just drink beer and wine these guys
drink really hard liquor here or or
maybe shoot up I don't know okay so how
does haramaine continue he's got a by
the way an organization that sells some
uh snake oil out there and that's how he
makes his money so we often hear the
sentence out or this concept everything
is connected it's all one uh but how is
that true
space is what's connecting everything
then space is the great organizer space
is the thing that connects all things
okay so space is a thing it's all this
energy in there and it connects
everything okay but I want you to see
how he slowly drifts into where he wants
to take you to Consciousness okay if we
look at all the little fluctuations of
the vacuum all the rest of the mass in
the universe is represented with
holographically I wonder we got that by
the vacuum fluctuation inside one little
proton okay we're talking about vacuum
fluctuations inside a proton I guess
he's been there he he saw it there so
that one little proton is connected to
all other protons in the universe we
don't disagree there but what is he
connecting it with he's connecting it
with energy and where's this energy it's
the inside the space and space is what
creates matter
this is his notion okay and he says our
universe is holographic in nature why
does he say that well because everybody
in string theory is studying calligraphy
now they're into Holograms and the
holographic principle and so he knows
that that's popular he so he's trying to
get the right words in there so that he
can sell his snake oil that's what it's
all about okay so here he says
how he turns this energy into fields and
into feelings he's going to drift uh
into Consciousness or out of
Consciousness I guess I don't know
there's a flow of the universe around
you and a flow of the energy of the
universe inside you okay so now we have
this flow of energy is going around the
universe and also inside you this
Dynamic energy of the universe is
constantly flowing through all of space
inside each one of our atoms connecting
us all
so we have this energy that's constantly
flowing through every atom and that's
what's connecting you to me okay so I
don't know what kind of connections he's
talking about he's talking about
physical connections how am I connected
to you through this energy which is a
concept
and he says you can literally feel the
force of the universe inside you
okay I don't feel the force uh you know
sometimes I feel the alcohol but not the
force and flowing through you connecting
you to everything physical objects are
not in space but these objects are
spatially extended as what as fields
so you can see how he's using all this
verbiage he's just throwing words in
there that have no meaning
and he says look it's space that creates
matter and there's all this energy
whatever that is inside space and that's
what's flowing through every atom and
because it's flowing through every end
these rivers of energy these fields you
know that's what's connecting us
how it's connecting I mean can I untie
myself from you uh can I cut this energy
in you know with a scissor or something
and you know have my freedom from you so
I'm not connected to you
okay so uh this is this is the way he
finishes you know he starts out by
talking physics Quantum general
relativity space time he energy you know
uses these fancy fancy words and then he
goes in there and says this is how he
ends his presentation he says oh
kindness and love and fear and sadness
and joy and anger and stress
so this is what he ends this
presentation so what is he selling he's
selling all this Consciousness uh based
on energy energy belonged to so-called
physics actually mathematical physics
and the Consciousness belonging to his
religion I don't know if he's trying to
win a Templeton prize which is a prize
given to those who try to merge
so-called science or mathematical
physics actually with religion with the
spiritual World they have this conscious
Universe in in the back of their minds
and so yeah the question is what are
these people talking about what have you
learned from them they're just using
mystical words they're selling you snake
oil you know the snake oil Peddler he
said oh by my Elixir you know it's good
for you that's all they're doing they're
just using words what do they sell to
you what's the bottom line what have we
understood about the universe with all
these people talking about the flow of
energy through atoms uh this energy
that's throughout the Universe whatever
it is because it fills space so
hopefully it's a thing but is it smoke
is it a gas well what is this energy
thingy and so it's this energy that's
flowing and if it's flowing how can it
connect us
and suddenly you know that energy
morphed into feelings and anger and who
knows what and suddenly you have
Consciousness flowing in there right
behind it so that's how they introduce
it in there
okay
so uh
yeah the two universes that we propose
uh we have the mathematical physics
Universe bunch of particles which is
what I started the presentation here
today with and that's the universe
everybody has and everybody proposes no
one has ever proposed anything different
everybody says just particles and even
those who propose The Ether and they
talk about blobs they don't realize
they're talking about what the blob is
made of which is particles
and that's why it's fluid that's why
it's uh malleable because it's made of
discrete entities called particles
corpuscles or whatever so this is the
mathematical physics world uh how did um
uh Stephen Hawking Define it he says an
event is a point in space time what is a
point it's a DOT what is a DOT it's a
vibration of a field a local vibrational
field everything's made of field what is
a field well it stretches infinitely you
know there's no end to it and that's how
they leave the room so so they say oh by
the way we don't understand anything but
further Universe he doesn't speak our
language anyways so we cannot hope to
understand him he doesn't understand us
what do we propose instead well we have
this parallel universe that is different
than uh the one of discrete particles
we're saying all atoms are physically
physically interconnected they're
connected to each other any atom uh
hydrogen atom when I talk about atom is
connected to any other hydrogen atom in
the universe and bigger atoms are simply
or bigger elements you can say you know
more massive elements such as iron
whatever lead they are made of more
hydrogen atoms so every hydrogen atom
that forms a uh an iron atom uh is has a
rope connected to any other hydrogen
atom in the universe okay that's a
proposal that's the Assumption it's
known as a hypothesis so that you know
our starting point you know that's how
we start our presentation and then based
on that we explain light gravity
magnetism electricity and so on workings
of the atom okay so
um all I can say is uh uh latecomer what
came in there uh put the comment today
so I didn't have really time to answer
him in a more uh complete way but he
asked uh what does uh not Theory uh have
to do with the Rope model and the answer
is absolutely nothing if you look up the
not Theory over there in um the
Wikipedia uh uh that's what you find
it's a mathematical concept okay and you
talk about knots like if you take any
strain you tie it in knots uh you get
all these different shapes and that's
what they mathematize and they try to
you know put equations on how to build
this in other words they they build an
equation that can simulate each one of
those uh
knots
okay that's all it is it's got
absolutely nothing to do with the Rope
model the Rope model is a physical model
and what is a physical model well we're
saying we have two uh atoms hydrogen
atoms and they're connected by a role
very simple think of a dumbbell not me
think of a Dumbo and and that's what the
Rope model is you have a rope that
connects two balls whether the ball Is
two hydrogen atoms and they're made out
of the same threads as the rope and the
atoms expand and contract and they
torque the Rope
baby stuff kindergarten stuff anybody
can understand it the universe is a very
simple
World simple Universe it's the
mathematicians who made it complicated
and it's the fact that they use math to
try to describe it that is very
complicated because if you've taken math
at the college level you know what I'm
talking about it's very complex okay you
take calculus you take uh you know
linear algebra and so on it's very very
sophisticated math okay and uh but
that's just to describe that doesn't
explain anything to explain you need
physical objects and that's when you go
back to kindergarten play with blocks
that's how simple it is two balls
connected by a rope uh the ball is
expanding contract these two balloons
expand and contract they torque the Rope
that's light and uh when you have many
atom when you what you have is gravity
kindergarten stuff for anybody
we'll see you next week with that bye
bye